sexually safe for work and pensions hi
good morning thanks for joining us
um obviously we want to talk about the
BBC
reports this morning that a number of
senior staff at the BBC are openly angry
at the way the corporation have handled
the situation are you well I think this
is a fast moving situation by the sounds
of it we seem to have revelation after
Revelation including the one last night
that the individual concerned at the
center of this is not satisfied with the
complaint that has been made by his
mother and his stepfather and I think
under these circumstances we shouldn't
be trying to prejudge exactly what's
happening and whether things are being
handled in precisely the right way or
not because we don't know enough of the
detail but what I do know is that the
Secretary of State for culture medium
and Sport had a meeting a discussion
with the director general of the BBC to
impress upon him the importance of
getting to the bottom of this as quickly
as possible and I'm absolutely certain
that that will be what's happening now
the police are involved as well at the
moment just by way of an inquiry not a
criminal investigation so I think that's
a distinction that's important as well
doing that however let's talk about the
timeline should we I mean um
the families say they approach the BBC
in mid-may either the 18th or the 19th
depending on which report you read
you're a father of three I think aren't
you yes
um how would you feel if you contacted
the BBC concerned about the safety of
one of your children and they appear to
have taken no action to prevent one of
their employees from allegedly behaving
in this fashion well I'm a father of
three children and I'd be very concerned
for my child if I was in the kind of
situation that this individual's mother
and stepfather appear to be in but you
did use the word appear to be and I
think that's a critical thing and that's
why I don't think we know enough of the
facts to be able to cast judgments on
some of these questions at the moment
well but there are many parts this very
many where's the child getting the money
from well there are many serious
questions to be answered here but what
I'm saying is I don't think any of us
yourself including Kane know enough of
the facts to be able to start opining as
to whether things are happening in
exactly the right way or not what
matters is that they're getting on with
it the government has lent into this in
the right way once it's all over and
concluded I think that is most certainly
the time to be looking at whether things
were done correctly or not but at the
moment it seems to me this is a highly
fluid unknown situation and we should
give the BBC a bit of space push the BBC
and say my child is a crack addict
please can you stop one of your
employees
enabling that by giving them money you
would think that they would be looking
into that
as I say I I think that that is one
interpretation of one aspect of what
male may have happened here but what I'm
saying is this has to be looked at
entirely in the realm the police are
involved in making inquiries they don't
appear at this moment in time to have
decided that a criminal threshold has
been exceeded they may or may not in the
due course of time who knows but I think
the important thing is that we don't
know enough of the facts to be able to
start pointing too many fingers yet at
the process I think we have to wait till
this has played out as quickly and
effectively as possible and that's what
the secretary of state has been pushing
for sure and then we can start to make
those judgments I'm sorry should the
presenter be named well I think that's
in the same category so at the moment
that individual has been suspended and
that does seem to me to be the right
thing to do but I I I I don't think I'm
in a position to be able to judge that
for the reasons that I've given I think
if we had all the facts in front of us I
think we could make that call and we put
it this way the longer the presenter
goes unnamed the more damage it causes
to the BBC and also to other presenters
who are having having their names
dragged through the mod they're having
to come out and say it's not me it's not
me it's a question uh I would suggest of
Integrity shouldn't the presenter come
forward to clear his colleagues names
well as I say we're going to keep going
around the same argument which is well
these are important things that you're
you're suggesting may occur like
somebody coming forward and saying I'm
the soft state or to be revealed as a
suspect and I think those decisions have
to be taken on the known facts and it
seems to me that even the apparent known
facts seem to be changing within 24
hours it's quite a significant thing to
come out and say it's not me it's a
matter of Integrity well that's a matter
for the individual concern but as I say
we don't know the facts of exactly what
is happening here and I think we're not
therefore in a position to start saying
this should happen that should happen
you can only do that when you really
know the facts and at the moment even
those apparent facts seem to be changing
uh almost by there so would you implore
your colleagues not to name him under
parliamentary privilege later in the
week as they are suggesting they will I
can only speak for myself as a very
personal thing I would personally
certainly not be doing that now members
of parliament do have a right to
privilege and to be able to say things
to the commons without fear of legal
repercussions but I think that is a
privilege that should be used very
sparingly and with great thought so I
can only speak for myself and say that
that is certainly something that I would
not choose to do I would want to see
process uh continue here as quickly as
possible and that is what the Secretary
of State the media and uh culture has
been doing has been pressing the BBC to
do that I'm as confident as I can be
that they will be now moving at PACE and
I think we have to see where all of this
lands and then start to make these
judgments about whether things were done
the right way or not so whether people
should be named or not and so on and so
forth okay let me put it this way to you
if the BBC was approached two months ago
which the mother whose child is a crack
addict says she did she said that she
showed them the bank balances where the
money was coming from 35 000 pounds by
this wholesome
presenter who has a household name and
reputation
um she approached them and they did the
square root of nothing until the son
contacted them sometime later two months
later to say look and she says she's
done that in order to keep her child
alive yes
they have questions to answer most
certainly if that timeline proves to be
the case
what should happen well if that is the
case that will be a case I think at
least of whether the complaint was
escalated quickly enough because it
clearly is an extraordinarily serious
complaint yeah but I think but I think
the time to make that judgment is when
all of this has gone through its various
stages and we know exactly what happened
now it may or may not be that it was
escalate I don't know it may or may not
be there were good reasons why it's
taken time the family say another
payment was made by the uh presenter
well the individual concern is now
saying that the whole story is rubbish
so things have moved around as I say I
think it's really important that all of
us resist to the extent that we can the
urge to opinion on what was right or
what was outrageous and wrong until we
know all the facts and the important
thing is that this is in touch with what
my viewers are thinking this morning
let me tell you how I feel yeah
absolutely right absolutely right and
that's why I'm asking you perfectly
entitled to your opinion and we want it
this morning of course does the Sun have
questions to answer today as to why they
didn't reflect in their reporting last
week on what the uh the young person at
the center of this controversy had to
say by the lawyer so so what I've heard
which I guess is what you've heard is
that on Friday of last week the
individual concerns lawyer got in touch
with the son to explain that in his
opinion these uh accusations were
unfounded
um I don't I don't know you know whether
that's absolutely right I don't know
what the sun's reasons might have been
for uh if they did indeed get that
communication I don't know whether they
did I don't know whether they've
commented even on that at the moment and
therefore once again I think we just
have to wait until everything has worked
its way through and then I think we can
dissect it in the round take a holistic
over what time scale and look at these
points well as soon as possible
well I I I can't be drawn into saying by
certain days
well I very much doubt so given that we
are spending a lot of time talking about
it the the Press is spending I I don't
absolutely it's a very serious matter so
I have no issue with that but my point
is that I think given where this this is
landed in terms of the news cycle and
the attention that it's getting it seems
inconceivable to me that anybody is
going to drag this out any longer than
it needs to be so I strongly suspect
it's being looked at robustly and with
vegan now well sincerely hope so just a
quick thoughts uh obviously I want to
talk about wage figures this morning
suggestions that public sector pays
fueling inflation doesn't this sort of
put pay to that
well there's been a slight softening in
the rate of increase in wages but we are
still in a difficult inflationary
situation now inflation is coming down
of course it's high in other countries
uh as well but we do need to keep
bearing down or not now that's a
combination of the bank of England doing
its bit on the monetary policy side but
it's also the government doing its bit
on the fiscal policy side which means
amongst other issues keeping on top of
uh pay settlements and if those do run
away of themselves I'm afraid that the
pain of higher inflation for longer will
be there and of course inflation itself
is something that impoverishes us all is
it's it's making us all poorer so we
have got to really go for that Target
the prime minister's set of halving
inflation by the end of the year and if
we can do that there'll be pressure off
not just Cost of Living issues but also
mortgage rates for example which is
another important issue at the moment I
must let you go we could talk all day
thank you I I know you have to Tiptoe
Through The Raindrops on that story but
it's really important and our view is
very very interesting it's a totally
understand yeah thanks very much thank
you